[Music]
[Applause]
2024 will be a record year for elections
around the world over 4 billion people
more than half of Earth's population are
expected to cast a ballot seven out of
10 of the most populous nations are
going to the polls and many elections
will be in countries consequential to
the news
cycle Taiwan held its presidential
elections on Jan January 13th which saw
William lie of the democratic
Progressive Party win with over 40% of
the
vote Li's election is expected to make
relations between Taiwan and Mainland
China more
antagonistic both Ukraine and Russia who
remain locked in war with one another
have scheduled elections in
March and US elections in November are
bound to draw intense International
attention in what is shaping up to be a
rematch of the 2020 election
democracy is still at risk this is not
hyperbole many academics political
analysts and think tanks expect 2024 to
be a major stress test on the concept of
democracy itself and one particular
variable that will further complicate
this test is the rise of AI tools and
the ability to create convincing deep
fake news
[Music]
content we're entering an era in which
our enemies can make it look like anyone
is saying anything at any point in time
even if they would never say those
things moving forward we need to be more
Vigilant with what we trust from the
internet that's a time when we need to
rely on trusted news sources deep fakes
and cheap fakes are not new but with the
explosion of AI that was ushered in by
the introduction of chat GPT just over a
year ago we saw deep fakes proliferate
and the types of deep fakes that we've
been looking at which are these fake
news segments using the real likeness
and real logos of real news outlets and
the faces of real broadcasters are
seemingly new and they are particularly
problematic right now as we are heading
into a really high-stake selection and
also as we are in the midst of a war we
have seen deep fake news segments from
Top prominent anchors at all sorts of
outlets ranging from CNN to CBS and
Beyond
truth or fake you're beginning with a
story of a video on social media where
president zalinski appears to surrender
to Russian forces what's that about a
false video of president zalinski was
diffused yesterday where he's apparently
making an announcement giving up to
Russian forces this video was diffused
on a hacked uh Ukrainian News website
called Ukraine 24 I've been seeing it
sort of come in and out for several
years now but in really seeing it
consistently in high quality I would say
in the last 12
months there's two main reasons for it
one is that the technology to create
deep fakes of news anchors has just
gotten better but two and I think this
is also important is that most of the
major social media companies have
eviscerated their trust and safety teams
and that's not just Twitter by the way
that one's easy but it's even the
Facebooks of the world the YouTubes and
the Tik toks and so as a result of that
when people create fake content it's
much much easier to distribute so
remember that when we're talking about
deep fakes there's there's really three
parts to it there's the underlying
technology the Bad actors who are
misusing the Technologies but then
there's the spread of that and the
spread of that technology is not an AI
question that's a social media question
all three things have now lined up the
technolog is getting better Bad actors
are figuring out that you can monetize
or or or abuse this this content and the
social media companies have fallen
asleep at the wheel
again using video from the CBS News
archives Chris Umi was able to train his
computer to learn every aspect of my
face and wipe away the decades this is
how I looked 30 years ago he can even
remove my mustache there are two
approaches to detecting manipulated
media what we call Proactive and
reactive
so the reactive is sort of my bread and
butter here as an academic at UC
Berkeley what we do is we take an image
an audio or video we run it through a
battery of tests and we try to figure
out if it's been manipulated or AI
generated all after the fact right so
stuff gets online some a fact Checker
contacts us we analyze the content and
we eventually tell the fact Checker and
they eventually set the record straight
and meanwhile the whole world has moved
on and gotten defrauded to the tunea
millions of dollars so the reactive
stuff is good if you will as a
postmortem but but at the speed at which
social media moves half lifee of a
social media post can be measured in
minutes you're not there fast enough to
deal with the damage the proactive
techniques the way they work is that if
you pick up your phone and record
something or you are in the business of
generating AI content you can inject
into that content whether it's real or
AI generated a digital Watermark that is
cryptographically signed and then
Downstream your browser or a piece of
software can read that Watermark and say
nope I know that this is AI generated or
in fact that it is real and you can do
that instantaneously this only works
when you have good players so when Adobe
decides it's going to put watermarks
into its content well great I I trust
Adobe but a lot of bad players out there
and a lot of this code for creating deep
fakes is open source so if you have open
source and you've got some code in there
for inserting a watermark while the bad
gu's going to go in there and remove
that code and We're Off to the Races so
the watermarking absolutely Ely are
going to play a role here but they will
not in and of themselves solve the
problem because there's always ways
around this technology and there's open
source and there's bad actors but I'm
super supportive of that for the big
players like Adobe open Ai and mid
journey and maybe we Lop off half the
problem I'm being replicated by a
standin actor to read this monologue and
then my appearance and voice is changed
using artificial
intelligence so now that I've got your
attention let's send it back to the real
Brian Sullivan as we dive deeper into
this revolutionary technology some of
the more prominent clips that we had
found were actually from a Tik Tok and
YouTube Creator his name is Krishna
sahai some of his most watched and most
viral videos were news segments with CBS
anchors that interviewed him as the only
Survivor in a school shooting we are now
interviewing the only survivor of the
recent Texas school shooting high school
student Krishna sahai in one example he
was the shooter in one example he was a
Survivor and across all the examples he
was mocking the school shooting itself
we are now interviewing the only
Survivor in the recent school shooting
tick tocker Krishna saw High dude that
must have been absolutely traumatizing
what was going through everyone's head
man bullets du one of the most
interesting pieces of this and troubling
pieces of this is that in many cases the
Deep fake News segment that we found
were getting more views and more
virality than actual news segments from
those same Outlets that were posted to
their blue check verified social media
accounts around the same time one
example that we found was from Face the
Nation this YouTube and Tik Tok Creator
had a segment that was actually one of
his more innocuous segments that was
about a group of kids jumping in an
elevator and the elevator crashes down
and then they owe this building more
than half a million dollars in damage
over $560,000 in Damages liel after Tik
tocker Krishna s High destroys El so
it's not the most threatening example
but what was so fascinating about it was
that it was viewed more than 300,000
times and it used again the Face thetion
logo and on the face the nation's social
media account on Tik Tok the post from
the same day only garnered 7,000 views
so when fake news segments from a
creator that uses the Outlet's logo or
anchors from that station is in fact
getting more eyeballs than actual news
clips from the actual Outlets blue check
social media accounts you can see how
that could become extremely problematic
and deter people from actually following
what is considered real
[Music]
news so even deep fake technology is
protected by the First Amendment lying
is protected by the first amendment I
could make false state stents and I am
not going to be punished unless that
false statement carries some additional
harm with it direct harm usually harm
that is perpetrated against an
individual and frankly when you're in
you know you're in a situation talking
uh making political statements that's
the the strongest protection the first
amendment gives so a general statement
of a political nature which I think a
lot of deep fakes we're seeing in this
coming year will be are actually
protected even when they're lies
unless there is some direct harm that is
inflicted upon an individual or or even
you know to some degree a small segment
of society and what we're talking about
here are things like defamation oh you
know if I say something or if I use a
deep fake in a way that uh makes a false
statement about you harms your
reputation that would be something that
is now outside of the First Amendment
not protected by the First Amendment
while we do have a collective media
literacy problem in this country where
people don't know the difference
necessarily between news and opinion or
even within news the difference between
a good source and a not so good source
or an outright lying source that has an
agenda of its own we're getting better
with that I think people collectively
and this is anecdotal people
collectively are getting better at
identifying you know separating truth
from falsity it's harder when you bring
in video because they don't know the
same tells that were already being
trained to look for in printed or online
information so there's a level of
validity of variet it to something that
they see in video and they go oh it's
video it's really hard to fake that and
it's happening so much and frankly it's
mostly being perpetrated by people who
want to take advantage of you you know
we know that in the 2020 and 2016
elections a lot of the misinformation
during the election period was coming
from overseas from places we aren't
going to be able to get to to you know
to punish and I think that's probably
what's going to happen again which is
what makes it so difficult uh to to
combat this is the most comprehensive
report that we've gotten about the 2020
election and foreign interference by the
intelligence community and it does make
clear that this massive Russian
influence campaign was designed
orchestrated by Putin to denigrate Joe
Biden and to support the reelection of
President Donald Trump I want to read
I've heard people say look
disinformation deep fakes they can't
change an election and I don't think
that's true because if you look at the
last two election Cycles the difference
between one candidate or another in
terms of the electoral vote came down to
some 80,000 votes in a handful of States
you don't have to move tens of millions
of votes you have to move tens of
thousands of votes and not only that I
know where those votes are if I'm the
bad guy trying to interfere with your
election I know exactly what states I
know exactly what towns what localities
and I know how to find these people on
social media and manipulate them and
that I think should worry us you need a
series of defenses and so you need a
series of proactive defenses and a
series of reactive defenses
and you need better corporate
responsibility and you need some
liability and you need some regulation
and you need good consumer uh protection
and so you know when you put all those
pieces together I think we can start to
trust things that we see online a little
bit
more it's possible it's difficult both
in a legal sense and a practical sense
to bring a defamation lawsuit against
someone based on their their creation of
a deep fake so let's let's just say you
create a deep fake about me I have to
show very specifically that not only you
lied you harmed me in some way and
specifically you harmed my reputation ah
but beyond that I have to show a number
of other things I have to show us
specifically that you made a materially
and
substantially false assertion of fact
about me that was published and harmed
my reputation and that you did it with
some level of
fault this ability to create so many
images so rapidly it's an incredibly
powerful tool new artificial
intelligence technology makes it easy to
create fake images that can look very
realistic like these created by artist
and online trust and safety expert Tim
bushe I think absolutely we are going to
see the campaigns use it against their
opponents we also can see campaigns
using it to bolster their own opponent
to create images of them looking more
heroic or taller for example but here's
the other place that we can that the
candidates can use it imagine now
there's a hot mic of a candidate or
sitting president saying something
inappropriate or illegal they don't have
to cop to it anymore they can say it's
fake and so they can also deny reality
so the Deep fake technology is a
double-edged sword you can create
harmful content but you can also dismiss
real content by simply saying it's fake
and muddying the waters I think the most
important thing right now is to remind
people to think before they share to be
a bit skeptical of what they are
consuming and to really try to pay
attention to the source
if the source is an authoritative news
Outlet great I don't think we can rely
anymore on which accounts are blue check
verified accounts and which aren't
because now we know that many of the
social media platforms allow people any
person to purchase verification or the
bar is significantly lower for verified
accounts but I think that you should
really be focused on where the news is
coming from who is posting it what their
motive may be and what sorts of
perspectives they are including in the
clip I think all of those things are
able to help us especially in a very
fast moving news environment better
calculate what is worth sharing versus
what isn't and help us better understand
what we are
consuming we do not want the government
to step into these discussions about
truth and falsity we don't want the
government to step into decisions about
this is my opinion this is your opinion
this is the right opinion we want the
government to stay out of it we have a
concept in the United States called The
Marketplace of ideas and what it says is
we have a place where we can all come
together and buy and sell not products
or Goods but thought ideas values and in
that Marketplace of ideas we not only
get to test our own thoughts and and
maybe change what we believe we may be
able to change other people's opinions
but we're also reinforced in what we
believe and the whole point though is we
get to sort it out for ourselves we know
that phrase uh that exists uh lie
travels halfway around the world before
the truth can put its shoes on I think
now the LIE travels around the world
once twice three times before the truth
even wakes up right we've dealt with
technological changes before throughout
our nation's history the First Amendment
remains unchanged it's it's it's been
there all along and it's worked and I
believe in the First Amendment and I
believe it's going to work this year as
well thanks just one last thing while
we're rolling how do I know you're not
deep faking me right now
that's one of my worries I mean it we're
sitting here about deep fakes we can
turn I don't even know if I see this I
how will I even know whether you're deep
faking me definitely won't
deep